c'est un rassemblement politique
mais on dirait surtout qu'une vedette
est attendu dans cette petite ville du
new hampshire
il y à la sécurité des organisateurs
nerveux et des partisans bien motivés et
comme aux grands concerts certains sont
arrivés tôt est venu de loin il a
conduit pendant trois heures pour venir
ici mais n'aurait jamais traversé la rue
pour entendre l'actuel président on est
ici pour voir une célébrité mais aussi
pour le politicien il aime le
franc-parler de tripoli
son style direct agressif celui-ci
compare les autres politiciens à des
marionnettes qui agissent sur tout pour
plaire à leurs donateurs
on croit que donald trump ne sera pas
facilement manipulable parce qu'il
finance lui-même sa campagne
celui ci croit que le milliardaire est
l'antidote cousine du passif qui siège à
washington
et on est prêt à lui pardonner ses
travers et même ses insultes aux femmes
ça fait plus de 40 minutes que les
portes sont ouvertes et encore des gens
qui attendent des gens qui espère
rentrer pour voir donald trump cette
vedette dans la course jusqu'à présent
la plupart des gens qui sont là pourront
pas bien sûr est dans la salle
principale donc les organisateurs ont
prévu une salle supplémentaire pour
qu'on puisse voir le candidat pour tous
ceux venus assister à un bon spectacle
le milliardaire ne déçoit pas
la foule impatiente d'accueillir enfin
le riche homme d'affaires qu'elle voit
déjà président
il est divertissant s'adresse au public
de manière conviviale et street à salir
et wet
il raconte des anecdotes passe d'un
sujet à l'autre rapidement délecte
pipeau groupe parle d'emplois
manufacturiers perdu d'immigration
illégale a freiné de concurrence
déloyale venant de la chine
la foule adore lorsqu ils dénigrent les
dirigeants américains et promet de
restaurer l'honneur des états unis oui
c'est que même en répondant aux
questions de la foule
donald trump demeure direct et se permet
d'interrompre un homme dans la question
lui semble trop longue
à la fin on a l'impression d'avoir
assisté au donald trump show un
spectacle plutôt qu'un discours
politique la vedette repart rapidement
et laisse derrière elle des électeurs
enthousiaste galloway certaines
convaincu que la victoire est proche
même si le vote aux présidentielles et
dans plus de neuf ici en exhumant baron
radio canada center new hampshire